Une des problématiques à prêcher de façon aussi rarement tous les deux mois, c'est qu'on arrive dans ce texte d'une façon un peu brute,
là où l'auteur a voulu prendre du temps pour que nous arrivions à ce chapitre 7 d'Hébreu, qui est le cœur de l'Épitre aux Hébreux.
Et donc nous y arrivons immédiatement dans le cœur de cet Épitre.
Et de quoi parle ce chapitre 7 que nous allons méditer ensemble ?
Eh bien tout le chapitre 7, tout le cœur de l'Épitre a à voir avec le sacerdoce de Christ.
Autrement dit, pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas ce mot, Christ en tant que prêtre.
Christ le seul vrai prêtre.
Christ le véritable prêtre que le monde attendait.
Le voilà enfin arrivé.
Et l'auteur en fait dans la dynamique de l'Épitre aux Hébreux a préparé le chemin par le chapitre 6,
notamment pour que nous puissions arriver au chapitre 7 avec solennité et révérence.
Et cela devrait être, même si cela fait longtemps que nous ne sommes pas arrivés dans ces versets,
notre disposition de cœur ce matin.
Nous sommes en Terre Sainte.
Nous parlons d'un des offices les plus importants de Jésus-Christ.
Oui, nous pouvons parler de Jésus-Christ de bien différentes manières,
et le monde parle de Jésus-Christ de bien différentes manières.
Mais ici, nous sommes dans quelque chose de tout à fait fondamental dans la compréhension de qui est Christ.
Christ n'est pas simplement un bébé né dans une auberge.
Il n'est pas simplement un homme qui a une bonne conduite morale.
Il est le prêtre de l'humanité.
L'office sacerdotal de Christ.
Et ce chapitre 7, en réalité, est considéré par les commentaristes comme étant une prédication du verset 20 que nous avons lu précédemment,
dans le chapitre 6,
qui est elle-même une citation du psaume 110 que Nathanel a lu pendant les offrandes.
Donc, l'auteur cite les psaumes,
et dans le chapitre 7, il va faire toute une prédication sur ce verset 20.
Donc, je relis ce verset 20.
« Jésus est entré pour nous comme précurseur,
ayant été fait souverain sacrificateur pour toujours,
selon l'ordre de Melchisédech. »
Et voilà le nom mystérieux dans les Écritures qui réapparaît soudainement.
Melchisédech.
Qui est ce Melchisédech ?
Et tout l'argumentaire de l'auteur dans ce chapitre 7
va être de nous convaincre, de convaincre les Juifs,
de convaincre les Hébreux,
que l'ordre de prêtre de Melchisédech est infiniment supérieur
à l'ordre de prêtre établi dans la religion judaïque.
De sorte que maintenant,
maintenant que vous avez été éclairé par Jésus-Christ,
maintenant que vous avez vu dans l'histoire l'avènement de Jésus-Christ,
vous n'avez plus besoin de regarder un nouveau sacerdoce.
Il y a un nouvel ordre en place,
qui d'ailleurs préexistait à l'ordre judaïque,
à l'ordre de Lévi, comme vous le savez,
les prêtres descendaient de la tribu de Lévi.
Il y a un autre ordre qui existe,
et maintenant que Jésus est là,
ce nouvel ordre réapparaît,
et l'ordre lévitique est rendu complètement obsolète.
La transition est actée entre la nouvelle et l'ancienne alliance.
Tout converge maintenant vers Christ.
Plus besoin de mettre votre confiance dans des saints,
dans des prêtres,
tout converge vers Christ,
du temple à Christ,
des sacrifices à Christ,
de la prêtrise à Christ.
Plus aucun besoin de mettre votre confiance
dans une religion ancienne,
et revenir à ce système,
remettre sa curiosité dans la religion de leur père,
pour les Juifs,
ça constituait pas simplement un retard
dans cette transition nouvelle,
ça consistait comme une insulte
pour ce que Christ a fait de façon suffisante.
Donc pour les Juifs qui ont été exposés à Christ
et qui ont professé Christ,
le fait de revenir à la religion de leur père
constituer une insulte
au regard de ce que Christ a fait
de façon suffisante pour eux.
Ce que Christ dut payer.
Et donc, nous sommes déjà arrêtés sur ce verset 1
lors de notre dernière prédication,
et je vous invite à la réécouter
si vous n'avez pas pu le faire,
sur cette appellation de Melchisedec
qui est le sacrificateur du Dieu très haut.
Ce que nous devons comprendre dans ce chapitre 7,
mes frères et sœurs,
surtout si vous arrivez en cours de série de prédication,
c'est que tout ce qui sera dit au sujet de Melchisedec
sera dit au sujet de Jésus-Christ
dans toute sa plénitude.
Tout ce que nous avons pu observer
dans cet homme, Melchisedec,
un homme mystérieux,
eh bien l'auteur divinement inspiré
va faire usage de Melchisedec
pour révéler la plénitude
de la perfection
de l'office de prêtre de Jésus-Christ.
Et donc nous nous étions déjà arrêtés
sur cette description de Melchisedec
dans le verset 1
qui est défini comme étant
le sacrificateur du Dieu très haut.
Et nous étions déjà arrêtés,
je ne vais pas revenir dessus du tout,
sur comment l'apôtre montre
par cette appellation
sacrificateur du Dieu très haut
à quel point Christ est infiniment supérieur
à l'ordre des Lévitiques,
à l'ordre de la prêtrise sacerdotale
du judaïsme.
Et maintenant nous allons mettre notre emphase
sur une deuxième description de Melchisedec.
Quelle est cette description ?
Verset 1.
En effet, ce Melchisedec,
roi de Salem.
Voilà ce que l'auteur va dire
au sujet de Melchisedec
et il va le dire plus loin
au verset 2 à nouveau.
Donc, il est d'abord roi de justice
d'après la signification de son nom,
c'est-à-dire Melchisedec.
Melchisedec signifie roi de justice,
mais il est aussi roi de Salem,
c'est-à-dire roi de paix.
Donc, nous avons un prêtre ici
qui est tout à fait extraordinaire,
qui est à la fois prêtre
et à la fois roi.
Quelque chose de tout à fait extraordinaire
dans l'histoire biblique.
Et pour comprendre
quelle est l'intention de l'auteur
en rappelant à deux reprises
qu'il s'agit,
que notre prêtre s'agit
d'un roi de paix,
pourquoi ?
On peut se poser la question.
Pourquoi dans ce chapitre
qui a à voir avec la prêtrise de Christ,
pourquoi il s'embarrasse
à nous parler de la royauté de Christ ?
Après tout, il y a plein d'autres versets,
chapitres dans la parole de Dieu
qui parlent de la royauté de Christ,
mais pourquoi dans un chapitre
spécifique à la prêtrise de Christ,
pourquoi semble-t-il faire un détour
en parlant de la royauté de Christ ?
Et en particulier
de l'aspect roi de paix.
Quelle est la logique de l'auteur ici ?
Quelle est son intention ?
Pour pouvoir répondre à cette question,
on doit comprendre à nouveau
et faire ce travail à nouveau
de comprendre
quel est l'état des Hébreux
lorsque l'auteur écrit.
Et on peut imaginer
aisément,
à la lecture de l'Épître aux Hébreux,
plusieurs raisons et motivations
pour lesquelles les Juifs
ont commencé à remettre leur confiance
dans l'ancienne religion.
premièrement,
la raison la plus évidente,
ce sont les persécutions
qu'ils ont connues.
La persécution de la part des Juifs,
même de leur propre famille,
et par peur du déchirement familial,
par peur de quitter une tradition
dans laquelle ils ont grandi,
même une tradition presque divine,
parce que cette religion
a été instituée par Dieu lui-même,
eh bien,
certaines personnes ont commencé
par pression,
par peur des conflits,
eh bien,
à faire des compromis
et à commencer à remettre
leur confiance
dans l'ancienne sacrificature.
Mais nous voyons
d'autres motivations,
d'ailleurs,
qui ne sont pas exclusives,
ces choses peuvent aller ensemble.
Premièrement,
il se peut que les Hébreux,
que certains Hébreux,
soient attirés
par l'aspect ancien
d'une religion,
tout simplement,
par l'aspect stable
d'une ancienne religion.
Et alors qu'ils découvrent
le christianisme,
c'est-à-dire la plénitude
du judaïsme,
quelque part,
eh bien,
certaines personnes
vont leur dire,
là,
c'est une religion nouvelle.
Comment tu peux mettre
ta confiance
dans une religion nouvelle
alors que la nôtre,
ça fait 2000 ans
qu'elle existe ?
Et certains Hébreux
vont commencer
à être sensibles
à ce discours
et à mettre
leur confiance
ou leur intérêt
dans une structure
qui est établie
et qui paraît
plus ancienne
simplement parce
qu'elle est ancienne.
Si des esprits brillants
ont réfléchi
sur la question
du judaïsme
pendant 2000 ans,
qui suis-je,
moi,
pour remettre
tout ça en question ?
Les monuments,
la structure
me rappellent la stabilité
de cette religion,
c'est qu'il doit y avoir
quelque chose de vrai.
Voilà le discours
auquel certains Hébreux
étaient sensibles.
Revenir
à l'ancienne
sacrificature
qui paraît vraie
à cause
de son ancienneté.
Deuxièmement,
il y a d'autres personnes
et d'ailleurs,
ces motivations
sont tout à fait
contemporaines,
encore aujourd'hui.
Deuxièmement,
une autre motivation,
c'est des personnes,
des Hébreux
qui voient
dans l'ancienne religion,
le judaïsme,
une religion
un petit peu
plus stricte
selon les règles externes,
une apparence
de piété externe
qui les attire.
Ils voient
la simplicité
du christianisme
dans laquelle
ils ont été enseignés
et en parallèle,
ils voient des personnes
qui se mettent des codes,
qui se mettent des règles
alimentaires,
vestimentaires
et ils se disent
dans leur fort intérieur
« Non mais,
si ces personnes
vivent de cette façon
pour Dieu,
avec autant de piété,
s'ils sont prêts
à ne pas manger
pendant toute la journée,
s'ils sont prêts
à faire
des longs voyages
jusqu'à la Mecque,
s'ils sont prêts
à se lever
pour prier le matin
avant que le soleil se lève,
c'est qu'il doit y avoir
quelque chose de vrai
parce que leur rigueur
extérieure est supérieure
à la nôtre,
se disent-ils
de façon erronée.
Et donc,
ce discours
chez les Hébreux
en regardant
l'ancienne sacrificature
résonne dans leur cœur.
S'il y a des rites,
s'il y a
une complexité
et une rigueur
dans l'ancienne
sacrificature,
c'est parce qu'il doit y avoir
quelque chose de vrai.
Et enfin,
une autre motivation
tout à fait contemporaine,
c'est celle des personnes
qui sont attirées
par l'ancienne sacrificature
pour l'aspect mystique
de la relation à Dieu.
Une relation qui n'est pas
vraiment
à proprement personnelle
mais plus,
selon eux,
spirituelle.
on s'avance vers Dieu
par des rites
un peu mystiques
qu'on ne comprend pas
tout à fait.
Mais il y a un mécanisme
par lesquels
Dieu va agréer nos prières
si on se comporte
de cette façon.
Alors,
je déconnecte quelque part
ma raison
parce que Dieu
est spirituel
et que
quiconque arrive
avec de la raison
et de la logique,
c'est un obstacle
à la vraie spiritualité.
Parce que Dieu
est spirituel,
nous devons nous avancer
et nous laisser aller
dans la spiritualité
sans même comprendre
exactement ce qu'on fait.
Voilà un des attraits
de l'ancien sacerdoce également.
Des personnes
qui s'avancent
avec des rites,
avec des mécanismes,
avec des rituels mystiques,
sans rapport personnel
à Dieu.
Et cela a eu
de la résonance
certainement
parmi les Hébreux
également.
Mais le grand paradoxe
de toutes ces tentatives
de la part des Hébreux,
c'est que la paix
qu'ils pensaient trouver
dans cette apparence
de religion,
dans cette fausse religion,
non pas que le judaïsme
véritable était faux,
bien entendu,
mais ce qui a été
compris et cru
du judaïsme
a été évidemment erroné
dans le temps de Jésus,
cela est évident.
Mais ce qui est
tout à fait paradoxal,
c'est que la confiance
et la paix
qu'ils pensaient trouver
dans cette nouvelle religion,
cette ancienne religion,
pardon,
eh bien c'était une paix
complètement trompeuse.
et tôt ou tard,
ils allaient se rendre compte
de la désillusion
de mettre leur confiance
à nouveau
dans des rites,
dans des prêtres,
à nouveau
dans une façon de vivre,
dans des codes moraux,
etc.
Tôt ou tard,
tous les efforts,
même les plus rigoureux,
s'avèreront être un échec
et leur paix
sera menacée.
La paix qu'ils pensaient
trouver dans ces systèmes
religieux
sera,
tôt ou tard,
ébranlée.
Pour certains d'entre eux,
ils connaîtront
cette désillusion
de leur vivant.
C'est-à-dire que la paix
qu'ils pensaient avoir
dans ces systèmes,
dans ces sectes,
dans ces fausses religions,
dans leur rapport
légaliste à Dieu,
eh bien un jour ou l'autre,
Dieu,
dans sa grâce,
leur permettra
d'avoir une perception
de sa sainteté,
des exigences absolues
de la pureté,
la perfection totale
que Dieu attend.
Ou alors,
ils ressentiront
dans leur fort intérieur
la culpabilité
de leur conscience
à cause des actes
qu'ils feront.
Et alors,
leur paix va s'évaporer
en une seconde.
Ils verront que
tous les artifices
de leur religion,
dans leur rapport à Dieu,
eh bien cela n'aura
aucun poids
lorsqu'ils feront face
à la sainteté de Dieu.
Ils seront comme Esaïe
lorsqu'ils voient Dieu,
et qu'ils crient
malheur à moi
parce que je suis impur.
Et ceux qui ont,
parmi nous,
et je sais que c'est le cas,
ceux qui ont marché
dans des sectes
pendant plusieurs années
connaissent bien ce sentiment.
Lorsque pendant des années,
ils ont dû
acheter leur paix
avec Dieu
par des pratiques
strictes et rigoureuses.
Ne joue pas au foot
avec tes enfants.
Ne te coupe pas les cheveux.
ne va pas au cinéma.
Et au fur et à mesure
qu'ils commençaient
à atteindre
ces standards,
eh bien la paix
disparaissait.
Ces gens-là
n'étaient pas caractérisés
par la paix.
Mais au contraire,
la perception
d'un Dieu
contre nous
grandissait de plus en plus
dans leur cœur.
Et dans sa grâce,
ceux qui sont dans notre Église
aujourd'hui
ou dans d'autres Églises
en bonne santé,
ont réalisé de leur vivant
la désillusion de cette paix.
une paix trompeuse,
une paix menacée
par l'attrait
à un système légaliste.
Et ceux qui connaîtront
cela de leur vivant,
cette désillusion,
soit cela produira
une tristesse profonde
qui conduira
à la conversion,
soit cela produira
une tristesse profonde
qui conduira
à la mort.
Dépression,
anxiété,
ils sauront
dans leur conscience
qu'ils sont coupables
devant Dieu,
mais ils essaieront
de maquiller cela
par des efforts.
Une tristesse
qui mène
à la mort,
comme le décrit
l'apôtre Paul.
Et malheureusement,
ce qui est d'autant
plus dramatique,
c'est que beaucoup
connaîtront cette désillusion
de leur paix
à leur réveil
après la mort.
Parce que la Bible
le décrit
de façon très claire,
notamment dans Job,
beaucoup de méchants
et d'injustes
finiront leur vie
dans un sentiment
de paix.
Avec l'assurance
dans leur cœur
que lorsqu'ils se réveilleront,
ils verront le sourire
sur le visage de Dieu.
Une paix trompeuse,
et ils seront alors
bien étonnés
quand ils se réveilleront
et qu'ils seront considérés
par Dieu lui-même
comme des ennemis éternels.
Manque de paix.
Ils seront dans la tourmente
à jamais.
Absence de paix.
Une paix menacée
par la structure ancienne.
La paix est une quête
universelle
de chaque homme.
Et même le chrétien
peut voir sa paix
être dérobée.
Lorsque des nouvelles
nous surprennent
dans notre vie,
lorsque nous faisons face
à de l'anxiété
dans notre cœur,
la paix peut facilement
se dérober
dans le cœur du chrétien.
Et certains parmi nous
qui sont d'origine
même ukrainienne,
dont les nations
sont elles-mêmes
en guerre,
connaissent cette aspiration
encore plus profonde
après la paix.
Il y a une aspiration
profonde de l'homme
pour vivre la paix,
pour enfin voir
l'arrêt des guerres,
pour enfin arrêter
de voir des familles
continuellement endeuillées.
Et même dans des nations
comme la France
sur lesquelles il n'y a pas
de guerre sur le sol,
nous voyons chaque jour
ce manque de paix
se manifester.
Conflits, luttes,
meurtres,
injustices,
viols.
Une nation caractérisée
par un manque de paix.
Par des conflits internes.
Et même sans parler
de manifestations externes,
le français est en manque de paix.
Nous n'avons jamais parlé
autant d'anxiété,
des anxiétés réelles.
Nous n'avons jamais parlé
autant de dépression,
de burn-out,
des choses qu'on n'a jamais
entendues quand nous
on était des enfants,
des collégiens
qui tentent de se suicider.
Des enfants,
des adolescents
qui sont obligés
de prendre des somnifères
pour s'endormir.
Anxiété.
Aucune paix
pour leur âme.
Une nation
en recherche
de paix.
Mais ce que la Bible
décrit en parlant
de la paix,
elle ne décrit pas
simplement un sentiment.
Lorsque nous parlons
en tant que chrétiens,
Dieu nous donne la paix,
on ne parle pas
simplement d'un sentiment.
La Bible parle
d'un état,
d'un statut,
être en paix,
déclarer en paix.
La réalité,
c'est que tout
ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui
de nos yeux
comme étant
des manifestations
de conflits
et de manques
de paix
ont une racine
encore plus profonde.
Les conflits
entre les nations,
les conflits
entre les hommes,
entre les familles,
les conflits internes
dans nos âmes,
dans nos pensées,
eh bien,
ce sont simplement
des symptômes
d'un conflit
encore plus grand.
Et donc,
l'homme a tort
de chercher
à traiter ces symptômes
simplement comme symptômes.
parce que la réalité
biblique,
c'est que lorsqu'elle parle
de paix,
elle parle d'une paix
encore plus grande,
plus profonde,
celle de la paix
que l'homme avait
entre Dieu
et lui.
Et l'homme
a été privé
de cette paix
ou plutôt,
l'homme a rejeté
cette paix,
cet état de paix
dans le jardin.
Il a commencé
à se rebeller
contre Dieu
et depuis,
il est en état
de guerre
contre Dieu.
Je répète,
l'homme,
naturellement,
est en guerre
contre Dieu.
Absence
de paix.
Et c'est de cette
absence de paix
profonde
de sa relation
avec Dieu
que vont jaillir
toutes ces crises
et tous les conflits
dans son cœur.
Et on le voit
de façon très explicite
dans la Bible,
absence de relation
de paix
entre Dieu
et l'homme,
qu'est-ce qui suit ?
Meurtre au fratricide.
Guerre entre l'homme
et l'homme,
entre frères
et frères.
La source,
c'est l'absence
de paix
avec Dieu.
Et je pense
que parfois,
on oublie cette réalité
que l'inconverti
est considéré
par Dieu
comme un ennemi.
Et ce n'est pas
simplement
un ennemi de Dieu.
Cet homme
a pour Dieu
son ennemi.
Il a pour ennemi
Dieu lui-même.
On peut décrire
nos bien-aimés
qui sont inconvertis
de bien des manières.
c'est un bon papa,
c'est un bon mari,
c'est une gentille jeune fille,
c'est une personne
avec des bonnes valeurs.
Mais la réalité
telle que la Bible
nous le décrit,
c'est qu'une personne
n'a pas été réconciliée
avec Dieu,
elle est considérée
comme un ennemi
de Dieu.
Elle vit
selon les passions
de sa chair.
Tout est orienté
selon les passions
de sa chair.
Et la Bible
dit très clairement,
les passions
de la chair
sont en inimitié
contre Dieu.
C'est-à-dire
que cette personne,
l'inconverti
qui n'a pas été
réconciliée avec Dieu,
peu importe
les bonnes valeurs
qu'elle puisse paraître,
elle déteste
ce que Dieu exige.
Elle déteste
l'exigence
de la perfection
absolue
de la part de Dieu.
Elle déteste
la notion
d'autorité
de Dieu
sur sa vie.
Elle déteste
le fait
que Dieu
exige
une perfection
absolue
totale.
elle veut être
un Dieu
pour elle-même.
C'est ma vie,
c'est mon choix.
Pas de Dieu,
pas de maître.
Autonome,
rébellion.
Je veux être libre,
je veux m'émanciper
de Dieu.
Un rejet total
de l'autorité.
C'est ce que Paul
décrit dans Romain
en chapitre 8.
L'affection
de la chair
est inimitié
contre Dieu
parce qu'elle ne se
soumet pas
à la loi de Dieu
et qu'elle ne le peut
même pas.
donc,
non seulement
elle ne désire
pas
se soumettre
à Dieu
mais encore plus
elle ne le peut
même pas.
Elle est esclavage,
esclave de sa situation,
de sa condition.
Esclave d'une condition
d'inimitié
et de guerre.
Ce sont des sujets
d'un royaume
ennemi de Dieu.
Ce sont des esclaves
qui ont choisi
volontairement
leur esclavage
et qui se plaisent
dans leur esclavage.
Regardez la description
biblique de ces personnes.
Fils de la rébellion
nous dit l'apôtre Paul.
Enfant de colère
écoutez bien
ces termes de guerre.
Enfant de colère
fils de la rébellion.
Et le plus terrible
mes frères et sœurs
c'est que ces personnes-là
parmi elles
beaucoup d'entre eux
ignorent cette condition
et vivent
même en professant
le nom de Dieu
et même pour certains
en professant
le nom de Christ.
mais elles ignorent
qu'elles sont en guerre
contre le Dieu vivant et vrai.
Et ce qui est terrible
c'est qu'un jour ou l'autre
cette guerre
se manifestera
devant leurs yeux
lorsque le Dieu vengeur
reviendra.
Et lorsque Dieu reviendra
ce sera un Dieu terrible
pour les inconvertis.
Un Dieu effroyable.
Et alors
l'absence de paix
la paix menacée
se manifestera
pleinement devant leurs yeux.
Ils n'auront aucun endroit
pour se cacher.
ils feront face
à un père
qui viendra juger
ceux qui auront foulé
à leurs pieds
son fils.
Ceux qui n'auront pas
capitulé devant son fils.
Absence de paix
se manifestera
pour l'éternité
pour eux
dans une oppression éternelle
dans des souffrances
vives et éternelles.
Absence de paix.
Et à moins de suspendre
complètement notre raisonnement
ici-bas
par des médicaments
par la création
d'un autre Dieu
qui a des exigences
infiniment plus basses
Dieu m'acceptera
si je ne manque pas de cochon.
À moins de se créer
ce type de Dieu
à moins de remplir
son temps
qui sont propices
à la pensée
et à la remise en question
par des divertissements
par la musique
visuels
et bien l'homme
sait au fond de lui
qu'il n'est pas en paix
et qu'il rencontrera
Dieu tôt ou tard.
Malheureusement
beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui
même dans cette compréhension
qu'ils vivent
dans une anxiété
au lieu de traiter
la source
vont aller voir
notamment des psychologues
qui ne vont jamais
traiter la source
qui vont essayer
de retracer
dans notre schéma
pour trouver
d'autres sources
de culpabilité.
Ce sont tes parents
c'est ton éducation
ce sont les traumatismes
que tu as connus.
Il y a une part de vérité
dans cela
dans les souffrances
que nous vivons actuellement
mais ce que la Bible décrit
c'est que le manque de paix
a pour source
une absence de paix
entre l'homme
et Dieu lui-même.
Alors la question ici
pour revenir à notre texte
quel est le problème
des Hébreux ?
Quel est le problème
de l'homme
de façon générale ?
Si on n'est même pas capable
de régler la paix
entre les hommes
comment l'homme
peut-il songer
régler la paix
entre le Dieu
qui est dans le ciel ?
Nous avons besoin
de quelqu'un
qui vient établir
cette paix
maintenir
et conserver
cette paix
autrement dit
le roi de paix.
Voilà ce dont les Hébreux
ont besoin d'entendre.
Eux dont la paix
était menacée
par l'ancienne sacrificature
eux dont la relation
à Dieu
était continuellement
instable
ils ont besoin
d'un prêtre
parce que
l'office premier
d'un prêtre
écoutez-moi bien
l'office premier
d'un prêtre
est de venir
accomplir
toutes les conditions
requises
pour que la paix
puisse être
actée
entre Dieu
et les hommes.
Donc je répète
l'office du prêtre
est de venir
accomplir
ou rendre possible
cette paix
par le sacrifice
qu'il offre.
Et l'office du roi
est de venir
appliquer cette paix
de façon individuelle
à son peuple
à ses sujets
de venir conserver
et maintenir
cette paix.
Autrement dit
ce que les hébreux
ont besoin
c'est d'un prêtre
qui soit aussi
un roi.
C'est d'un roi
qui soit
au service
de sa propre
prêtrise.
Et tout ce
qui nous est dit
au sujet
de la royauté
ici dans ce chapitre 7
n'est pas un sujet
annexe
dans le chapitre 7.
Cela vient
enrichir
notre compréhension
de l'efficacité
de la prêtrise
de Jésus-Christ.
Tout ce qui sera dit
dans ce chapitre 7
concernant le roi
Melchisedec
mais directement
Jésus-Christ
cela a pour objectif
de venir
enrichir
notre confiance
dans la prêtrise
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Donc quel est
l'objectif
de l'épître aux Hébreux ?
Je l'ai déjà répété
lors de la dernière
prédication.
Quel est le but
de l'épître aux Hébreux ?
Oui,
effectivement,
on peut dire,
on peut répondre,
c'est de montrer
la supériorité de Christ.
C'est vrai.
Mais quel est
l'objectif expérimental
pour le chrétien ?
Quelle est l'intention
de l'auteur
dans tout ce chapitre
ou dans même
tout cet épître,
dans toute cette lettre ?
L'objectif ultime,
il nous est donné
dans le chapitre 4
au verset 16,
c'est que le chrétien
puisse s'approcher
de Dieu
avec confiance,
avec assurance
du trône de la grâce.
Ça,
c'est la raison ultime
pour laquelle
l'apôtre a écrit
toute cette épître,
pour que nous cessions
de vivre comme des chrétiens
anxieux,
pour que nous cessions
de vivre de façon
apeurée,
avec un rapport
dilettante avec Dieu,
de yo-yo avec Dieu,
avec un intérêt
pour l'ancienne
sacrificature.
Pourquoi ?
Non seulement
parce que Dieu
veut que nous vivons
notre vie
dans notre plein potentiel,
une vie avec abondance,
donc pour notre bien,
Dieu veut
et il est préoccupé
à ce que nous soyons
des chrétiens
assurés,
pleins de confiance,
mais aussi pour sa gloire
parce que Dieu
est glorifié
quand une race déchue
qui a été rachetée
vit maintenant
pleinement pour sa gloire,
avec confiance,
avec audace
et c'est une atteinte
à sa gloire
en tant que chrétien
que de vivre
de façon continuellement
anxieuse
dans un rapport
d'inimitié
comme d'inimitié
avec Dieu,
un Dieu contre nous.
Dieu
est préoccupé
à ce que nous soyons
confiants
et pleins d'assurance,
donc ça c'est l'objectif.
Maintenant,
comment fait-il
pour nous assurer
que nous pouvons
nous approcher
avec assurance
du trône de la grâce ?
Eh bien,
en nous assurant
de l'efficacité
du ministère de Christ.
Ce que Christ a fait
est suffisant,
c'est historique,
c'est ancré dans l'histoire,
c'est suffisant
de sorte que tu peux
arrêter d'être apeuré
et t'approcher
avec audace
du trône de la grâce,
avec la certitude
que tu y trouveras
un sacrificateur
qui te regardera
avec un regard favorable.
Et comment
il veut nous assurer
de l'efficacité
de Christ ?
Eh bien,
dans ce passage,
en revêtant
l'office de prêtre
par l'étoffe royale.
C'est un prêtre
qui est aussi roi.
Est-ce que c'est clair
pour vous ?
Voilà l'objectif
de ce chapitre 7.
Dans cette introduction,
j'en conviens
assez longue,
mais je crois nécessaire.
Donc,
la question que nous allons
nous poser lorsque nous allons
étudier ce verset maintenant,
comment par l'usage
de Melchisedec,
l'office de roi de paix
assure la supériorité
du sacerdoce de Christ ?
C'est une très longue question,
je repose.
Comment par l'usage
de ce roi Melchisedec,
eh bien,
l'office de roi de paix
va manifester
et attester
la supériorité
de Christ
en tant que prêtre
devant toutes
les fausses religions,
incluant
le mauvais rapport
à l'ancien sacerdoce ?
Donc,
on va voir
cinq éléments
de réponse
dans ce verset.
Premièrement,
le caractère
pacificateur
du roi
garantit
l'efficacité
de la prêtrise
de Christ.
Deuxièmement,
l'autorité royale.
Troisièmement,
la puissance royale.
Quatrièmement,
l'efficacité royale.
Cinquièmement,
la générosité royale.
La compréhension
de la générosité royale
viendra nous assurer
de l'efficacité
de la prêtrise
de Christ.
Commençons
sans tarder.
Premièrement,
donc,
le caractère
pacificateur
de ce roi,
donc Melchisedec,
mais au travers
de Melchisedec,
Christ lui-même,
garantit
l'efficacité
de la médiation
de Christ.
Donc,
lorsqu'on revient
très rapidement
dans Genèse
au chapitre 14
qui relate
cette rencontre
entre Abraham
et Melchisedec,
j'invite
à regarder
le nombre de rois
impliqués
dans les conflits.
Ici,
Genèse 14,
versets 1 et 2,
dans le temps
d'Amraphel,
roi de Chiniat,
d'Arjoc,
roi de Lazare,
de Kédor-la-Homère,
roi des Lames,
et de Tidéal,
roi de Goïne.
Donc là,
c'est les premiers rois.
Il arriva
qu'ils firent la guerre
à Béra,
roi de Sodome,
Bircha,
roi de Gomorre,
à Chiniat,
roi d'Adma,
à Shemehéber,
roi de Tseobim,
et au roi de Béla,
qui est Tsoar.
Donc là,
c'est l'arrière-plan
de la rencontre
entre Melchisedec
et Abraham.
C'est une description
d'un conflit,
d'un monde en guerre,
des rois
qui affrontent
d'autres rois.
Insécurité,
guerre,
violence.
Et Dieu,
contrairement
à d'autres conflits,
ici,
ne semble même pas
prendre parti
pour une nation
ou une autre
dans ce récit.
C'est simplement
une description factuelle,
historique,
d'un monde en guerre,
de rois
qui s'affrontent
les uns
contre les autres.
Et vous noterez
dans ce chapitre 14
que nous avons lu
en introduction
que le seul roi
qui ne fait pas partie
de cette guerre,
c'est Melchisedec,
le roi de paix,
le roi de Salem.
Melchisedec
apparaît
dans ce conflit
à la fin du conflit,
à la fin de la guerre.
C'est le seul roi
d'une façon extraordinaire
qui non seulement
ne participe pas
à cette guerre,
mais qui vient
à la rencontre
d'Abraham
pour célébrer la paix,
célébrer le triomphe
d'Abraham
sur ses ennemis.
Il apparaît
dans le texte
comme étant un roi
qui est presque
au-dessus des conflits,
au-dessus des guerres
qui ont lieu.
Et il rencontre
Abraham,
ou Abraham
à l'époque,
sortant d'un royaume,
le royaume de paix,
qui lui-même
n'a pas connu la guerre.
Melchisedec sort,
il ne fait pas partie
de cette guerre,
il vient à la fin
de la guerre,
il rencontre Abraham
et il célèbre la victoire,
il célèbre la paix,
il célèbre le réconfort,
il célèbre le repos
avec Abraham.
Il n'a pas d'autre
ambition géopolitique.
On peut imaginer
un roi qui arrive
à la fin d'une guerre
justement,
qui essaye de faire usage
de sa puissance militaire
pour étendre son royaume
et profiter de ces rois
qui sont en déroute,
de ces royaumes
qui sont maintenant
fatigués de la guerre.
Et maintenant,
ce roi tout neuf,
tout frais,
il arrive dans le combat
et il prend position
des terres.
Ce n'est pas du tout
l'ambition de Melchisedec.
Melchisedec arrive
à la fin de la guerre
pour célébrer la paix,
pour célébrer le triomphe
de la paix avec Abraham
et ensuite,
il s'évapore aussitôt.
Il se tint devant Abraham
et il disparaît aussitôt.
Et cela est tout à fait cohérent
avec le royaume
dont il vient.
D'où vient Melchisedec ?
Là, c'est une question
qu'on ne pourra pas aborder
dans toute la profondeur,
mais Melchisedec vient de Salem,
la ville de Salem.
Donc, en langue sémite,
Salem veut dire paix.
Et cela est tout à fait cohérent,
sa démarche pacificatrice
est tout à fait cohérente
avec le royaume
dans lequel il vient.
Donc, encore une fois,
on ne va pas se plonger
dans qu'est-ce que peut être Salem
d'une façon profonde.
Ce n'est pas le but
de cette prédication,
mais je serais ravi
d'en discuter avec vous
à un autre moment
si vous le souhaitez.
Mais juste aborder
trois positions historiques
sur cette ville de Salem.
Premièrement,
la ville de Salem
a été comprise
par certains,
historiquement,
comme étant la ville de Salim
qu'on retrouve dans les évangiles,
notamment Jean chapitre 3.
Et notamment Saint Jérôme,
qui est historien,
admet qu'ils ont trouvé
des ruines
dans cette ville de Salim
qui ont l'apparence
de ruines de palais royal.
Et donc,
cela suggérerait
qu'un roi puissant
habiterait dans cette ville
qui aurait changé de nom
de Salem à Salim.
Et ce roi pourrait être
le Melchisedec
qui a rencontré Abraham.
Deuxièmement,
une autre opposition
et celle-là,
elle est plutôt défendue
par une partie
de ceux qui pensent
que Melchisedec
n'était pas un homme
comme les autres,
mais était même pas
un type de Christ,
mais Christ lui-même,
avant son incarnation,
eh bien,
selon une partie
de ceux qui ont cette position,
ils pensent que Salim
n'est pas un royaume
local réel.
Mais plutôt,
dans l'apparition,
dans la Christophanie
avant son incarnation,
Salim est plutôt relatif
à un royaume symbolique,
un royaume spirituel,
faisant référence
peut-être même
à la Jérusalem céleste.
Et donc,
ce Melchisedec
serait, selon eux,
Christ préincarné
qui s'avance
auprès d'Abraham.
Et selon
la majorité
des commentaristes,
Salim est bien
une véritable ville.
Et non seulement
c'est bien
une véritable ville
locale
et historique,
mais c'est l'ancien
nom même
de Jérusalem.
Salim
devenant
Jérusalem.
Et cet ancrage
historique,
il est même
ancré bibliquement,
puisqu'on trouve
notamment
dans le psaume
76,
un psaume
selon
Asaph,
qui dit,
qui parle
de Salim
comme étant
Jérusalem
elle-même.
La ville de Salim,
la montagne
de Sion,
Jérusalem.
La demeure
de Dieu
est dans Salim.
Donc,
selon ma compréhension,
au moins,
la ville de Salim
était bien
une ville
locale,
terrestre.
Et c'est une ville,
mais sans rentrer
dans d'autres
considérations,
considérons
ce qui est
explicitement révélé,
c'est une ville
qui est tout à fait
remarquable.
Pourquoi ?
Pensez-y.
Avant même
qu'Israël
n'existe,
donc on connaît
Israël,
quand on pense
à Israël
dans l'Ancien Testament,
on pense
temple,
culte à Dieu,
etc.
Avant même
qu'Israël
ne soit,
il y avait
un royaume
qui adorait
le véritable Dieu.
Un royaume
dont on sait
peu de choses,
mais dont
Melchisedec vient.
Dans cet environnement
polythéiste et païen,
il y avait un royaume
qui adorait déjà
le véritable Dieu.
C'est tout à fait
remarquable.
Et cela aura son poids
plus tard dans la supériorité
de Melchisedec
par rapport
à la tribu de Lévi.
C'est tout à fait remarquable,
d'autant plus qu'on sait
lorsqu'on lit la Bible
que le roi est souvent
le baromètre
de la santé spirituelle
du peuple.
Là où le roi va,
le peuple va aussi.
Le Dieu que le roi prie,
le peuple prie aussi.
Mais ici,
le roi de Melchisedec
est aussi
le prêtre
du Dieu très haut.
Autrement dit,
c'est un roi
qui offre
un culte agréable
à Dieu,
au seul Dieu
vivant et vrai.
Donc,
on peut
raisonnablement imaginer
que la ville
avec ce roi
établissait
un culte
agréable
à Dieu lui-même.
et Melchisedec
en tant que roi
de cette ville
qui a été nommée
dans l'aspiration
la plus profonde
de ce peuple,
la paix,
eh bien le roi
devait être
le garant
de cette paix.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle il était
roi de cette ville,
roi de paix,
pour garantir
la paix.
Non seulement
la paix extérieure,
de la protéger
des ennemis
qui pourraient
envahir la ville,
non seulement
maintenir la paix
intérieure
et faire usage
de sa puissance royale,
de son autorité royale
pour maintenir
la paix
à l'intérieur
de l'enceinte
de la ville,
mais surtout
comme nous l'avons vu,
pour établir la paix
entre ce royaume
et Dieu lui-même
en tant que prêtre
du Dieu très haut.
Melchisedec
avait une mission
principale,
garantir
la paix
dans un royaume
en paix
et sortir
de l'enceinte
de son mur
pour aller
célébrer la paix
avec ceux
qui sont en dehors.
Et encore une fois,
tout ce qui est dit
dans les dispositions
naturelles
de Melchisedec
dans ses prérogatives
premières
sont dites évidemment
au sujet
de Jésus-Christ
premièrement.
Car c'est le cas
de notre prêtre.
Nous n'avons pas
un prêtre classique.
Nous avons un prêtre
qui est selon l'ordre
du roi
que je viens de décrire.
C'est-à-dire
un prêtre
qui est aussi roi.
Et sa disposition
naturelle
en tant que prêtre
selon l'ordre
de Melchisedec,
Jésus-Christ,
sa disposition naturelle
est de chercher
la paix.
et de chercher
la réconciliation.
Ça fait même partie
des caractéristiques
qui sont annoncées
dans son ministère
bien avant son avènement.
Tout à l'heure,
Christian a lu
en introduction
ce que Esaïe
a prophétisé
au sujet
de l'avènement
du Messie
qui va arriver.
Un enfant
nous est né.
Donc,
ce sera un homme
qui naîtra
d'une femme.
Un enfant
nous est né.
Un fils
nous est donné.
La domination
reposera sur son épaule.
D'accord.
Ce sera un enfant.
Ce sera aussi un roi.
on l'appellera
admirable,
conseiller,
Dieu puissant.
Ça sera aussi un Dieu.
Père éternel,
prince de la paix.
Autrement dit,
ce Messie avait
comme prérogative première
de venir chercher la paix,
de venir réconcilier le monde.
et il sort des enceintes,
Jésus-Christ,
des enceintes
du royaume céleste,
là où la guerre
n'a jamais sévi.
Et il vient
dans un territoire
ennemi en guerre
pour venir
célébrer,
conquérir cette paix,
maintenir cette paix
en tant que roi.
Ça fait partie
de sa disposition
naturelle.
Oui,
c'est un Dieu redoutable
comme je l'ai décrit
dans l'introduction.
Oui,
c'est un Dieu
terrifiant
pour les inconvertis.
Mais la réalité
que le chrétien
doit se rappeler,
c'est que la disposition
naturelle
de votre Dieu,
c'est de chercher
la réconciliation
avec vous.
De sorte que le chrétien
est assuré
que dès lors
qu'il s'approche
du trône de la grâce
avec un cœur authentique,
il est assuré
de voir un Dieu
empressé
de chercher la paix
avec vous.
N'avancez pas
avec le pas léger,
courez vers votre refuge.
Vous êtes assuré
de trouver un prêtre
dont la disposition
naturelle
est de se réconcilier
avec vous.
Que le Dieu
de paix
soit avec vous,
dit Paul.
Voilà la caractéristique
de Dieu,
le Dieu
de paix.
Je vous laisse
la paix,
je vous donne
ma paix,
dit Jésus Christ
lui-même.
Et j'entendais ce matin
dans un podcast
en venant aux voitures,
quel est le premier mot
que dit Jésus
après sa résurrection ?
Shalom,
paix.
La disposition
naturelle
du Messie
est de chercher
la paix.
Son ministère
a tellement
à voir
avec la réconciliation
des hommes
qu'il est réduit,
résumé en ces mots,
ministère de la
réconciliation.
Votre prêtre
est prêt
à vous attendre,
à être réconcilié.
Il n'a pas
d'autre ambition
en venant sur terre.
Il n'a aucune
ambition militaire,
géopolitique,
à agrandir
son territoire
ici-bas
par les armes
des hommes.
Il est venu
nous réconcilier.
Deuxièmement,
l'autorité royale
de Christ
garantit
l'efficacité
de sa médiation.
Et ça
doit être comparé
avec l'absence
d'autorité
qu'avaient
les prêtres
lévitiques.
Non seulement
c'était une autorité
qui était déléguée
dans l'ancien sacerdoce,
les prêtres
devaient faire
exactement,
scrupuleusement
ce qui leur était
donné de faire
et malheur à eux
s'ils sont détournés.
Mais on ne peut pas dire
que le ministère
des prêtres
dans l'Ancien Testament
est peut-être décrit
par l'autorité.
Au contraire.
On pourrait plutôt
les décrire
par crainte,
par fragilité.
On se souvient bien,
même si pour eux
c'était un privilège
d'entrer dans le lieu
très saint,
de représenter le peuple,
le yom kippour,
c'est-à-dire
le jour de l'expiation,
c'était un sujet
de crainte
pour le prêtre
parce qu'il savait
qu'il allait s'approcher
d'un lieu
où la sainteté de Dieu
pourrait le consumer
sur place.
Et malheur au prêtre
s'il savait
qu'il était coupable
de quelque chose,
qu'il avait commis
quelque chose.
Malheur au prêtre
de se tenir devant
le Dieu omniscient
qui sonde
les reins du cœur
parce qu'il savait
que son impureté rituelle
ou que son impureté morale
pourrait causer
sa mort instantanée
dès lors qu'il franchissait
le seuil du temple.
Et on voit
dans la description
des habits,
notamment du prêtre
souverain,
donc du chef des prêtres,
le souverain sacrificateur,
qu'il y avait des cloches
à ses robes.
Et on sait que
l'hypothèse la plus probable,
c'est justement
que c'était tellement probable
qu'il meure dans la présence
de Dieu
qu'on mettait des cloches
pour essayer d'entendre
s'il marchait toujours
ou non.
crainte,
fragilité.
Et je rajouterais même
à cela,
qu'est-ce qui étonnait
les gens ?
Je vous invite vraiment
à relire les évangiles
dans cette perspective,
surtout quand Christ
s'adresse aux prêtres.
Nous avons les prêtres
de l'ancien sacerdoce
face aux véritables prêtres.
Et tous les échanges
qui ont eux,
vu sous cette perspective,
vont enrichir
votre compréhension
du dialogue
du vrai prêtre
face aux prêtres
de l'ancienne sacrificature.
Mais qu'est-ce qui caractérise
ou plutôt qu'est-ce qui étonnait
les gens
lorsque Christ parlait aux prêtres ?
Les gens étaient étonnés
parce qu'ils l'enseignaient
avec autorité.
Les prêtres n'étaient pas
marqués par l'autorité.
Mais notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ
est un prêtre,
mais il a l'autorité royale.
Il a l'autorité
que les prêtres n'ont pas.
Il n'entre pas
à la tête baissée
lorsqu'il entre
dans le lieu très saint,
lorsqu'il franchit
les portes du ciel.
Il a la tête levée
et il marche
d'un pas triomphant.
C'est un roi
qui entre
d'une façon conquérante.
Il ne vient pas
avec la peur
d'être accepté
ou ne pas accepté par Dieu.
Son entrée
est un triomphe.
Il n'entre pas
avec des clochettes
en bas de sa robe,
mais quand il entre,
ce sont les acclamations
des anges.
Ce sont le chant
de tous les saints.
C'est une entrée
triomphante.
Et il ne traverse pas
un rideau fait
avec des mains d'homme,
un rideau bien qu'épais.
Il traverse
les portes éternelles
du ciel.
Comme nous l'avons lu
en introduction,
voilà ce que
le psalmiste vit.
Portes,
élevez vos linteaux.
Élevez-vous,
porte éternelle.
Le psalmiste ici,
aperçoit l'entrée du prêtre
dans le lieu très saint.
Et c'est un prêtre
qu'il définit lui-même
comme étant roi.
Portes,
élevez-vous,
portes éternelles,
que le roi de gloire
fasse son entrée.
Qui est ce roi de gloire ?
L'éternel,
désarmé,
voilà le roi de gloire.
Combien cela contraste
avec la fragilité
de l'ancienne sacrificature.
Celui qui est entré
avec un triomphe humble
dans les portes de Jérusalem,
mais un triomphe
sous le chant de Hosanna.
Voilà le fils de David
monté sur un âne
est entré
avec le plein triomphe
dans toute la plénitude
de sa gloire,
dans les portes éternelles
du ciel.
Et rien ne s'oppose
à son entrée.
Il entre d'une façon
conquérante.
Même les fautes,
même nos fautes
passées,
présentes,
même les choses
les plus honteuses
qui ont causé
tant de dégâts
dans notre vie,
même les souillures
les plus abominables
que nous avons pu commettre
à Dieu
et à nos proches.
Rien ne pourra
disqualifier
l'entrée triomphante
de notre prêtre
qui est revêtu
de l'autorité royale.
Et lorsqu'il accomplit
son office de prêtre
sur la croix,
même le rideau du temple
ne peut pas se contenir.
Et il laisse la place
à l'entrée de ce prêtre
en se déchirant
de haut en bas.
L'autorité royale
de Christ
garantit
l'efficacité
de sa médiation.
Troisièmement,
la puissance royale
garantit
l'efficacité
de la médiation
de Christ.
Et là,
c'est à contraster
plutôt
avec l'instabilité
de la sacrificature.
Plusieurs hébreux
et même,
je dirais même,
plusieurs chrétiens,
malheureusement,
vivent leur rapport
à Dieu
de façon
dans l'insécurité,
dans l'instabilité.
En ce moment,
je vais bien avec Dieu
et la semaine prochaine,
non,
là,
ça ne va pas.
Je me suis trop éloigné.
Et cette instabilité
prend même
tant de place
que viennent
de nouvelles doctrines
dans leur cœur
qui leur privent
complètement de la paix
que Dieu veut leur donner.
Perte du salut.
Je crois que j'ai été
déshérité
des promesses de Dieu.
Je crois même
que je ne suis même
plus aimé de Dieu.
Et quelque part,
l'instabilité
de l'ancienne
sacrificature
devait faire naître
ce sentiment.
Jour après jour,
sacrifice.
Matin, sacrifice.
Soir, sacrifice.
Des milliers
de litres de sang
versés
pour que cette relation
puisse être maintenue
avec Dieu.
Yom Kippour,
des dizaines
et des dizaines
pour les plus écolos
d'entre nous,
de vaches égorgées.
si bien que
tous ces litres
de sang versés
devaient générer
dans le cœur
de l'adorateur
cette question
mais jusqu'à quand ?
Quand est-ce que
Dieu sera
enfin satisfait ?
Quand est-ce que
je serai enfin
rétabli
dans la paix
avec Dieu ?
À l'infini,
il faut encore
des sacrifices.
Il faut encore
que je donne.
Il n'y a rien
qui peut me rattacher.
qui peut me rétablir.
Et malheureusement,
plusieurs encore
aujourd'hui
qui ont été exposés
à la suffisance
de Christ
continuent de se rapporter
comme des mendiants.
La réalité,
c'est que notre prêtre
est aussi
le Seigneur des armées.
Il est aussi
le Roi
qui non seulement
vient conquérir
cette paix
mais vient maintenir
à jamais
cette paix.
Il est venu
nous conquérir.
amener nos noms
dans la présence
de Dieu lui-même
et il peut
maintenant
garantir
que nous allons
demeurer
éternellement
sous sa main puissante
dans cet environnement
de paix.
La logique de Christ
est simple.
Mon Père est fort.
Personne n'est plus fort
que mon Père.
Donc personne ne pourra
vous ravir
de la main de mon Père.
Si je vous ai acquis
dans cet environnement
de paix,
personne ne pourra
vous ravir
de cet environnement
de paix.
Nous sommes en train
de régner déjà
avec Christ
dans les lieux célestes.
Une réalité
qu'on ne peut pas
voir visuellement
aujourd'hui
mais Dieu nous a
déjà emmenés
devant sa face
dans les mains
de Jésus-Christ
comme une encre
qui nous lie,
comme une chaîne
qui nous lie
à Christ
dans les lieux célestes.
Il nous amène
dans son royaume
et il nous sécurise
et maintient
cette paix
maintenant.
Et c'est vrai
que la puissance
royale de Christ
on ne l'a pas encore vue
à proprement parler
de nos yeux.
On la verra un jour
certainement.
mais on a déjà
des aperçus
même dans sa condition
fragile terrestre
de la puissance
de Jésus-Christ.
Vous vous rappelez
dans ce jardin
Géthémane
une armée
qui vient à sa rencontre
pour le saisir
et il dit
je suis.
Et cette armée
qui tombe à terre
sous le simple mot
du roi puissant
et qui dit à Pierre
Pierre ne sort pas
ma défense
parce qu'il suffit
que je dise quelques mots
et les cieux
vont s'ouvrir
et une armée
vont venir
pour me défendre.
Voilà la puissance
royale
de notre prêtre.
Le fils de l'homme
dans Matthieu
ce n'est pas simplement
une référence
à l'humanité de Christ
ça fait référence
à ce que Daniel
décrit
un homme
qui a reçu
toute domination
sur terre
dans le ciel.
Autrement dit
aucune autorité
céleste
Satan lui-même
ni ses démons
n'auront
l'autorité
sur Christ
qui tient
vos noms
dans le lieu
très saint.
Ils sont
sujets à Christ
ils sont
soumis à Christ
il est
le fils
de l'homme
et personne
ne peut vous ravir
de sa main
et contrairement
à Melchisedec
comme Nathanel
l'a rappelé
dans les moments
des offrandes
Melchisedec
est venu
à la fin des combats
pour célébrer la paix
mais notre prêtre
est un roi
qui est lui-même
sorti au combat
c'est lui-même
qui a combattu
pour nous
c'est lui
qui est venu
dans un territoire
ennemi
et qui les a
livrés publiquement
en spectacle
sur le bois
de la croix
votre maintien
dans le lieu céleste
est garanti
cessez de vous
comporter
comme des personnes
dont la relation
à Dieu
est continuellement
instable
si vous avez mis
votre foi salvatrice
en Jésus-Christ
votre maintien
dans cet environnement
de paix
est garanti
par sa main puissante
par son autorité
royale
Christ peut sauver
parfaitement
tout ce que le Père
lui a confié
et il peut les garder
assurément
dans sa main
ferme
royale
voilà le prêtre
qu'on attendait
enfin
non pas un prêtre
qui égorge des agneaux
jour après jour
mais un prêtre puissant
qui garantit cette paix
et qui la maintient
quatrièmement
l'efficacité royale
de la prêtre
garantit l'efficacité
de la médiation
de Christ
et là c'est plutôt
à contraster
avec le manque
d'assurance
des prêtres
sous l'ancienne
sacrificature
parce que quand
les prêtres
s'approchaient
de la présence
de Dieu
c'était non seulement
dans l'espoir
déjà de survivre
mais c'était aussi
dans l'attente
que Dieu
réponde
à leur prière
et Yom Kippour
était une journée
de supplication
Seigneur
veuille répondre
à nos prières
veuille bénir
ton peuple
et si vous ajoutez
à cela
la corruption morale
des prêtres
comment pensez-vous
que cette intercession
sera acceptée
par Dieu
et le récit biblique
est plein
d'exemples bibliques
de prêtres corrompus
pour justement suggérer
dans le coeur
de l'hébreu
attendez un meilleur prêtre
et une fois
que vous avez reçu
ce prêtre
mais arrêtez
de retourner
à d'autres prêtres
arrêtez d'adorer
des saints
un pape
arrêtez de mettre
votre confiance
dans des évêques
vous avez reçu
le prêtre efficace
lorsqu'on pense
notamment à Élie
qui est non seulement
un prêtre
mais un souverain
sacrificateur
et ses fils
qui volaient
de l'argent
dans le temple
qui couchaient
avec des femmes
qu'est-ce qu'il nous est dit
dans 1 Samuel 3,14
l'iniquité
de la maison d'Élie
donc ses prêtres
ne sera
jamais expiée
ni par sacrifice
ni par offrande
écoutez
c'est parce que
ce message
est dramatique
pour Élie
il n'y aura
aucune provision
pour repêcher
aucune possibilité
de repentance
Élie
à cause de ce que
tes fils
ont fait
ni sacrifice
ni offrande
mais encore plus dramatique
que pour Élie
et pour ses fils
imaginez maintenant
le peuple
qui voit
leur avocat
imaginez-vous
devant le tribunal
de Dieu lui-même
vous savez
que vous êtes coupable
que vous êtes
trouvés coupables
par Dieu
et voilà
vous attendez
avec impatience
qui sera l'avocat
qui viendra me défendre
et vous voyez
les fils d'Élie
s'approcher
et le juge sait
que ses avocats
sont corrompus
le juge sait
que ses avocats
sont des fornicateurs
sont des adultères
sont des voleurs
et tout l'espoir
des accusés
qui disparaît
la moindre espoir
du peuple
qui s'évaporait aussitôt
à cause de la corruption
morale
des prêtres
alors comment espérer
que leur intercession
sera entendue
mais la réalité
c'est quand
dans l'efficacité
royale de Christ
nous trouvons
un réconfort
parce que lorsque
Christ rentre
dans le lieu
très saint de Dieu
il ne supplie pas
à Dieu
lorsque Christ
rentre dans
les lieux
très saint
et qu'il est
maintenant
avec ses mains
sur lesquelles
il y a le sang
de son sacrifice
Christ n'est pas
en train d'entrer
en espérant que Dieu
va pouvoir répondre
à sa prière
Christ rentre
en tant que roi
et il réclame
ce qui lui est dû
et lorsqu'il prie
à son père
bénit ce peuple
pardonne les iniquités
de ce peuple
sanctifie ce peuple
maintient ce peuple
glorifie ce peuple
il sait qu'il demande
ce qui lui revient
de droit
à cause des mérites
qu'il a obtenus
à cause de son office
en tant que roi
il ne fait pas
de prière chétive
timide
craintive
il demande
à Dieu
et il sait
que la réponse
sera un vibrant
oui
amen
si nous sommes assurés
dans les écritures
que la prière du juste
est d'une grande efficacité
que dire de la prière
du juste lui-même
tout ce qui sortira
de la bouche de Christ
sera
fera mouche
tout ce qui sortira
du soupir de Christ
sera répondu favorablement
devant
le père lui-même
il a une prière
efficace
son intercession
est sûre
ne te laisse pas
dérober ta paix
pourquoi crains-tu
au-dedans de toi
mon âme
des nouvelles
peuvent te surprendre
toi-même
tu peux te surprendre
mais tu as quelqu'un
qui est continuellement
en train de prier
pour ton âme
et tout ce qui sortira
de la bouche
de cet intercesseur
revêtu
de son étoffe royale
sera accepté
par la face
de Dieu lui-même
de sorte qu'il fera
concourir toutes
les circonstances
de ta vie
pour parfaire
ta sanctification
et pour t'emmener
avec lui dans la gloire
ne te laisse pas
dérober
ta paix
et enfin
j'aimerais finir
avec cet aspect
de la générosité royale
de la prêtrise
qui garantit
l'efficacité
de la médiation de Christ
lorsqu'on a lu
cette rencontre
entre Melchisedec
et Abraham
on a noté quelque chose
c'est que Melchisedec
donc se tient devant Abraham
et il fit venir
du pain et du vin
et on a l'impression
on peut avoir l'impression
quand on lit ça
qu'il vient avec un bout de pain
avec un quignon de pain
et nos coupes
de centaines
de centilitres
la réalité historique
ce qui est
beaucoup plus probable
c'est que lorsque
Melchisedec
s'avance auprès d'Abraham
il vient avec un ravitaillement
généreux
avec un lot de richesses
et c'est ce que les rois faisaient
et c'est ce qu'ils devaient faire
on le voit
Gédéon a aussi
cette attente
que les rois aux alentours
viennent le combler
pour le ravitailler
après avoir combattu
et donc lorsque Melchisedec
fit venir du pain
et du vin
c'était pour réconforter
non seulement Abraham
qui était fatigué
épuisé des luttes
mais c'était pour réconforter
toute son armée
avec lui
il a fait preuve
ici
dans sa célébration
de la paix
de générosité
royale
de sorte que même
plus loin
on voit Abraham
lorsqu'il reçoit
l'offre de Sodome
qui dit mais attends
mais j'ai besoin de rien moi
garde tes richesses
roi de Sodome
j'ai déjà été béni
spirituellement
et j'ai déjà été comblé
mon coeur est dans la joie
et le vin représente
souvent la joie
dans les écritures
j'ai déjà été comblé
et mes armées
avec toi
avec moi
sont comblées également
et d'ailleurs
c'est d'autant plus frappant
que dans le texte
verset 1
je trouve
c'est un bel euphémisme
de la langue française
il est dit
il revenait
de la défaite des rois
mais dans l'original
c'est le massacre des rois
c'est pas simplement
la déroute
c'est que Abraham
a participé
dans un combat
si dur
que certainement
il a dû lui-même
mettre fin
à la vie de ses rois
comme c'était le cas
dans le monde antique
le roi vainqueur
met fin
à la vie
du roi perdant
il revient
d'une lutte acharnée
d'une lutte sanglante
et maintenant
il trouve
de la réjouissance
après avoir été
épuisé du combat
voilà ce qui est merveilleux
mes frères et sœurs
concernant la générosité
de Christ lui-même
c'est que beaucoup
vont s'approcher
de Christ
de façon authentique
en espérant
trouver auprès de Christ
un prêtre
qui viendra expier
leur péché
en espérant
qu'ils trouveront
enfin un prêtre
efficace
qui pourra pardonner
leur faute
et les présenter
devant la face de Dieu
mais ce que beaucoup
ignorent
c'est qu'ils trouveront
également
un roi
qui viendra
les combler
de toute richesse
pour leur marche
pour leur piété
et pour leur glorification
ils trouveront
un roi
qui sera généreux
au point de les combler
le chrétien
ne manque de rien
aussi faible soit-il
aussi pauvre soit-il
sans ce monde
aussi ignorant soit-il
aussi peu diplômé soit-il
est comblé
de toute richesse
par son prêtre
qui est aussi un roi
et qui manifeste
envers nous
sa générosité royale
et beaucoup de chrétiens
ignorent cette réalité
et se comportent
comme s'ils devaient
attendre encore
une manifestation
d'amour de Dieu
envers eux
lorsqu'il a déjà donné
son fils
je manque de force
devant cette tentation
tu as déjà reçu
toutes les richesses
notre rôle
c'est de s'approfondir
dans ces richesses
c'est de persévérer
déjà obtenues
et Dieu communique
ces richesses
à son peuple
notamment à travers
l'église locale
au travers de cette prédication
lorsque Christ est exalté
c'est la façon
que Dieu a
de nourrir son peuple
lorsque nous prions
le vendredi soir ensemble
c'est la manière
que Dieu
oui tu te penses faible
mais saisis les richesses
que Dieu t'a déjà données
la lecture de la parole
la communion fraternelle
voilà les richesses
que Dieu te donne
pour réconforter
celui qui est fatigué
réconforter celui
qui est affligé
qui a besoin de force
mais d'une façon
encore plus magnifique
cette rencontre
entre Melchisedec
et Abraham
représente une rencontre
encore plus merveilleuse
encore
Abraham
qui représente
le père des croyants
qui est le père des croyants
qui est caché l'église
quelque part
et Melchisedec
ce type de Christ
cette rencontre
après les luttes
après les combats
nous ramène vers
une réalité
que l'église
rencontrera un jour
son prêtre
à la fin des combats
à la fin des luttes
acharnées
après avoir sué
contre le monde
les portes du ciel
s'ouvriront
et nous verrons
un prêtre
qui nous accueille
dans sa maison
et qui nous comblera
des richesses
d'un roi
il nous prépare
déjà une demeure
il garantit
notre présence
et il nous donnera
un ravitaillement éternel
nous allons boire
nous allons manger
de cet arbre
qui nous était autrefois
interdit
il sera lui-même
la source de vie éternelle
et il célébrera la paix
conformément à sa nature
ce sera une fête
lorsque nous rencontrerons
notre prêtre
et il célébrera
notre triomphe
sur nos ennemis
il célébrera
le triomphe
sur notre péché
il célébrera
le triomphe
sur notre mort
il célébrera
le triomphe
sur le monde même
dans lequel nous avons
vécu
et combattu
oui quand nous serons fatigués
et lorsque nos yeux
fermeront
nous rencontrerons
un roi
dans toute sa générosité
royale
plus de larmes
plus de guerre
plus d'anxiété
plus de douleur
plus de racines
d'amertume
le roi
maintient
et sécurisera
cet environnement
de paix
oui mes frères
c'est ce prêtre
dont nous avons besoin
dont les hébreux
avaient besoin d'entendre
un prêtre
d'un nouvel ordre
non selon l'ordre
des hommes
mais c'est le prêtre
dans lequel
nous pouvons avoir confiance
c'est un prêtre
qui est aussi
le roi de paix
un héros
qui sort au combat
comme aucun autre prêtre
l'a fait dans l'histoire
approchons-nous
avec assurance
de ce prêtre
qui possède
toute autorité
je vous invite à vous lever
pour lire ensemble
et conclure
en effet
ce Melchisedec
roi de Salem
sacrificateur
du dieu très haut
qui alla devant Abraham
lorsqu'il revenait
de la défaite des rois
qui le bénit
et à qui Abraham
donna la dîme de tout
qui est d'abord
roi de justice
d'après la signification
de son nom
et ensuite
roi de Salem
c'est-à-dire
roi de paix
Amen